voilà l'image qui provoque colère et
indignation du côté de la partie civile
la veuve de bernard laroche ne comprend
pas pourquoi la justice ali non quatre
fois et accepte la cinquième de libérer
jean marie villemin
elle n'accepte pas que le meurtrier de
son mari puisse réveillonner avec son
épouse christine qui est toujours
inculpée d'infanticide
je dirais que les termes de cette
décision comporte une attaque
personnelle de la part du président de
la chambre d'accusation et de la
majorité la chambre d'accusation à
l'égard de mes clients nous allons
sûrement faire un combat en cassation et
nouvelles révisions sont la suite des
opérations
en parlant avec les divers confrères
intéressés et avec nos clients est
remise en liberté assortie d'un contrôle
judiciaire qui vient d'être ordonné par
les hauts magistrats de la cour de la
chambre d'accusation de la cour d'appel
de dijon permettra la poursuite de
l'information de l'assassinât du petit
grégory dans le calme et sans
précipitation
après 32 mois de préventive jean marie
villemin devra vivre loin des vosges de
leur climat de haine et de vengeance
il est assigné à résidence dans le
département de l'essonne où il attendra
en famille que la justice statue sur
l'inculpation de sa femme christine
avant son propre renvoi aux assises